Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. This episode is going out on the 9th of August and it's a time of great stress for families and particularly for students across much of the country here in England because tomorrow on the 10th of August both A-Level and GCSE results will be announced. it's not normally done like this but obviously circumstances because of the pandemic are very different and the same thing happened last year and it last year particularly served as a reminder of how
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《The Rest Is History》。本期节目将于8月9日播出，对于英格兰大片地区的家庭，尤其是学生来说，这是一个压力巨大的时期，因为明天——也就是8月10日，A-Level（高级水平考试）和GCSE（普通中等教育证书考试）的成绩将会公布。这通常不是以这种方式进行的，但显然由于疫情，情况大不相同，去年也是如此，去年的情况尤其提醒了我们
fundamental exams are both to education and how we measure education and so Dominic we thought it might be interesting to ask why that is and where did the idea of exams come from how did they evolve what's that everything has a history doesn't it and exams are no different um yeah I first I did my first exam Tom when I was almost eight so we had formal exams from the age of you know from whatever year that is at my school and and the headmaster would announce the results in reverse order at assembly i mean some eurovision some people some people may say that's that's bad i i thought it was brilliant actually i love because you always you always came top did you i uh well it's not for me to say it's not for me to say how i did but i used to walk i used to walk out of
考试对于教育以及我们如何衡量教育是多么的根本，多米尼克，所以我们觉得问问为什么会这样，以及考试的想法是从哪里来的，它们是如何演变的，可能会很有趣，所有事情都有历史，对吧？考试也不例外。嗯，是的，汤姆，我第一次参加考试时，我差不多八岁，所以我们从你懂的那个年龄起——也就是我学校里相应的年级——就开始有正式考试了，校长会在全校集会上以倒序的方式宣布成绩。我的意思是，有些人可能会说这很糟糕，但我其实觉得太棒了，我非常喜欢，因为你总是能考第一，是吗？我，呃，好吧，这不该由我来说，这不该由我来评判我考得怎么样，但我过去常常
that assembly with a massive smirk on my face, put it that way. Probably utterly, I mean, if there's anybody from my school listening to this, this will just confirm all their worst fears. Well, I think, Dominic, in that case, we need to unleash on you and your monstrous smugness. One of the country's leading educationalists, Daisy Christodoulou, author of three books um founder of a company that is kind of daisy basically your company just quickly explain it because it's it's kind of revising the idea of exams isn't it sure yeah so hi hi tom hi dominic um yeah so our company we're called no more marking um we have a different technique that we use for assessing essays, assessing extended pieces of writing. It's called comparative judgment. And it's not new. It's not something that we invented. It was invented back in the 1920s. But what we've been able to do
脸上带着大大的坏笑走出那个集会，这么说吧。可能完全是，我的意思是，如果我学校的任何人听到这个，这只会证实他们最糟糕的恐惧。好吧，多米尼克，我想在这种情况下，我们需要把全国顶尖的教育专家之一——黛西·克里斯托杜卢（Daisy Christodoulou）释放出来，她写过三本书，呃，是一家公司的创始人，这家公司，黛西，基本上简单解释一下，因为这有点像是在重塑考试的概念，对吧？当然，是的，嗨，汤姆，嗨，多米尼克，嗯，是的，所以我们的公司叫做“拒绝再评分”（No More Marking），我们有一种不同的技术，用于评估论文、长篇写作。这叫做比较判断法。这并不新鲜。这不是我们发明的东西。它早在20世纪20年代就被发明了。但我们能够做到的是
is kind of plug it into a piece of software, which makes using it much, much quicker. So what teachers do instead of reading an essay or piece of writing and marking against a rubric, what they do instead is they'll see two pieces of writing on screen, on the computer screen. They'll read them both and they'll say to themselves, which is the better essay? Which is the better piece of writing? And they make a series of decisions like that. And teachers from across the country will make a series of decisions like that. And then we combine all of those decisions to come up with a measurement scale for every piece of writing. So it's a different way of assessment. It's much more reliable, it's more valid, and it's pretty quick as well.
有点像把它插入一个软件中，这使得使用它变得快得多、多啦。所以老师们不用去读一篇论文或文章并对照评分标准打分，他们所做的是在屏幕上、在电脑屏幕上看到两篇写作。他们会把两篇都读一遍，然后对自己说，哪篇论文更好？哪篇写作更好？他们会做出一系列这样的决定。全国各地的老师都会做出一系列这样的决定。然后我们将所有这些决定结合起来，为每一篇写作得出衡量标准。所以这是一种不同的评估方式。它更可靠，更有效，而且也相当快。
So exams is something you've thought a great deal about. I'm going to doubly embarrass you, first of all, by telling you what Amanda Spillman, head of Ofsted, how she described you. A fountain of energy and inspiration, Sherlock and Mycroft Holmes rolled into one. Wow. And Dominic, that couldn't be better
所以考试是你深入思考过的事情。我要对你进行双重羞辱，首先，我要告诉你Ofsted（英国教育标准局）负责人阿曼达·斯皮尔曼（Amanda Spillman）是如何形容你的。一个充满活力和灵感的源泉，福尔摩斯和麦考夫·福尔摩斯的结合体。哇。多米尼克，这再合适不过了
because we've got Sherlock Holmes coming up. Yeah, who's Moriarty in this analogy? Who's Dr. Watson? Well, I think I'm Dr. Watson. You're clearly, with your fiendish ability at exams and doubtless long division sons, you are Moriarty. The Napoleon of exams. The Napoleon, exactly.
因为我们接下来就要讲到福尔摩斯了。是的，在这个比喻里谁是莫里亚蒂？谁是华生医生？嗯，我想我是华生医生。你显然凭着你在考试中的恶魔般能力和无疑很熟练的长除法，你就是莫里亚蒂。考试界的拿破仑。拿破仑，没错。
But Daisy, also, I mean, essentially, we are your second favourite podcast, is that right? Because your favourite is our sister podcast. We Have Ways, done by my brother and Al Murray, all about the Second World War. Yeah, I'm a fan. I quite like it, yeah. You have a drinking game, is that right? You have a drinking game that you play
但是黛西，还有，我的意思是，基本上，我们是你的第二喜爱播客，对吧？因为你最喜欢的是我们的姊妹播客。《We Have Ways》（我们有办法），由我哥哥和阿尔·默里（Al Murray）主持，全都是关于第二次世界大战的。是的，我是个粉丝。我挺喜欢的，对吧？你们有一个饮酒游戏，是吗？你们会玩一个饮酒游戏
when you're listening to this World War-themed podcast? I think, you know, Tom's just throwing me under the bus here, aren't you, Tom? What do they do? They mention a panzer and you drink a pint of meths. I think their great phrase is, whenever they talk about an elite picked group of, you know, an elite group of picked men,
当你听这个以二战为主题的播客时？我想，你知道，汤姆只是把我推向火坑，对吧，汤姆？他们做什么？他们提到一辆虎式坦克（Panzer），你就喝一品脱工业酒精。我想他们最经典的口号是，每当他们谈到精选的精锐群体，你知道的，精锐的精选人员群体，
any sort of combination of those words, you have to drink. Tom, we should institute a rest-is Rest Is History drinking game or bingo card type arrangement, shouldn't we? But I think our episodes are so varied that it would be very difficult for people. But every time you mention something being sacral, that should definitely,
任何这些词的组合，你都必须喝酒。汤姆，我们应该设立一个《The Rest Is History》的饮酒游戏或宾果卡之类的安排，对吧？但我认为我们的节目太丰富多样了，对大家来说会很难。但每次你提到某样东西是神圣的（sacral），那绝对应该，
that should definitely be one of them. Shouldn't it? I don't think I repeat myself at all. I think I say something new every moment. Well, maybe we could throw this open to the listeners and see if they've got any suggestions for a Rest Is History drinking game. game but anyway we're being diverted um
那绝对应该成为其中之一。对吧？我觉得我一点也没有重复自己。我觉得我随时都在说新鲜的事。嗯，也许我们可以向听众征集一下，看看他们对《The Rest Is History》的饮酒游戏有什么建议。但无论如何，我们被扯远了，嗯
daisy exams where do they begin so the sort of famous example of where they begin in the famous sort of prehistory is in is in china so they go back an incredibly long way in china uh much much you know earlier than the the we start using them in the west um so as early as kind of really about the seventh century they've got the origins of exams yeah um but the origins of exams in china uh being used as um a means of selection for the civil service so that's the the kind of really big history with them in China. And these are written exams, are they, Daisy? So they seem to start off as maybe an oral interview, but they quickly kind of evolve into something that is written and they quickly become quite systematic, quite standardised.
黛西，考试是从哪里开始的？所以，关于它们起源的那个所谓著名例子，那个所谓的史前史，是在中国。所以它们在中国有着极其悠久的的历史，呃，比我们在西方开始使用它们要早得多、多得多。所以早在公元7世纪左右，就有了考试的起源，是的。嗯，但考试在中国起源时被用作……选拔公务员的一种手段——所以这是它们在中国真正宏大的历史。而且这些都是笔试吗，黛西？所以它们似乎一开始可能是口试，但很快就演变成书面的东西，并且很快变得相当系统化、相当标准化。
There's a whole kind of national infrastructure involved in administering them. So certainly you've got things in the West, perhaps in a bit more of an ad hoc way that might look like what we think of as exams, but nothing, as I say, as extensive or standardised as what's going on in China. And in fact, in the West in the 19th century, in the 18th and 19th century,
其中涉及一整套国家基础设施来管理它们。所以西方肯定也有一些东西，可能更具临时性，看起来像我们所认为的考试，但正如我所说，没有任何东西像中国那样广泛或标准化。事实上，在西方的19世纪，在18世纪和19世纪，
when a lot of reformers are looking at civil service, a lot of them keep going back to China and looking at what's happening there and praising it or critiquing it or thinking how we can do better. So John Stuart Mill, he talks about it in On Liberty. He talks about the Chinese exam system a bit there and the Chinese system of government. So it's something that when you get reformers in the 19th century thinking about how we should use exams in schools and for employment,
当许多改革者在审视公务员制度时，他们中的许多人不断回顾中国，审视那里发生的事情，赞美它、批判它，或者思考我们如何能做得更好。所以约翰·斯图尔特·密尔（John Stuart Mill），他在《论自由》（On Liberty）中谈到了这一点。他在那里稍微谈了一下中国的考试制度和中国的政体。所以当19世纪的改革者在思考我们应该如何在学校和就业中使用考试时，
that they are going back and looking at what's going on in China. And is that why we call top civil servants mandarins? Yeah, it absolutely is. So there's a Jesuit, Matteo Ricci. He's one of the first, I think maybe the first Westerner to visit China to actually kind of see what the Chinese state is like. I think he goes there in 1601. He spends a lot of time preparing for it.
他们会回过头去审视中国正在发生的事情。这就是为什么我们将高级公务员称为“满大人”（Mandarins）吗？是的，绝对是这样。所以有一个耶稣会士，利玛窦（Matteo Ricci）。他是第一批，我想可能是第一个访问中国并真正亲眼看到中国国家形态是怎样的西方人。我想他在1601年去过那里。他为此做了大量的准备工作。
You know, he sort of learns Chinese and he spends a lot of time kind of finding out what there is to know know about china at that time and he is really impressed by the exam system the way they select uh the way they use the exams and select the kind of best and brightest to run the country um and he he writes about it a lot and when he comes back and that's again where a lot of people in the west are sort of catching on to it getting interested in it and yeah it seems to be he's the one who um therefore comes up with the term Mandarin for a civil servant and is really impressed with the quality of all these civil servants. So let's unpack this a bit. So 7th century China. I guess what you need to have exams, you need a bureaucracy, a sort of national bureaucracy that can kind of either roll them out or bring people in to take the exams.
你知道，他学了中文，花了很多时间去了解当时中国的情况，他对考试制度留下了深刻的印象，他们选拔的方式……他们利用考试选拔最优秀、最聪明的人来治理国家的方式，呃，他对此写了大量的文章。当他回来时，这也正是西方许多人开始了解并对之产生兴趣的地方，是的，似乎就是他，呃，因此创造了用“满大人”来指代公务员的术语，并且对所有这些公务员的素质留下了深刻的印象。那么让我们来剖析一下。所以公元7世纪的中国。我想如果你要进行考试，你需要一个官僚机构，一种能够推广考试或将人们聚集起来参加考试的国家官僚机构。
But you also need a pretty high degree of literacy, don't you? I mean, people need to be able to, if there's a written element, you need an awful lot of people who can read and write. And in the West, certainly, that's not a lot of people. So I imagine even in China, you're talking about exams within quite a small segment of the population, aren't you? Because surely a lot of Chinese peasants can't read and write. Yes, it's really interesting. Yeah, really, really good point.
但你还需要相当高水平的识字率，对吧？我的意思是，如果包含笔试成分，人们需要能够读写，你需要大量识字的人。而在西方，这绝对不是很多人。所以我想即使在中国，你所说的考试也是在人口中相当小的一部分人当中进行的，对吧？因为肯定有很多中国农民是不识字的。是的，这真的很有趣。是的，非常、非常好的观点。
And so I suppose the 7th century is the very earliest origins of them. And they grow and grow, as I say. But yeah, it's definitely true. A lot of people who've written about it, including Matteo Ricci, have sort of reflected on the fact that if you look at maybe countries in the West, what they're doing at the time, China's instituting this big program of exams. It's pretty different. I don't want to come on this podcast and have a go at the heptarchy. I know Tom wouldn't be happy with me. That would be another tricky argument. But a lot of people who've written about this have reflected that as China's bringing in a kind of exam system at the same time as in England, you've got the heptarchy, which, as I say, on most podcasts, people will probably say it reflected badly on the heptarchy,
所以我猜公元7世纪是它们最早的起源。正如我所说，它们不断发展壮大。但确实如此，许多写过相关文章的人，包括利玛窦，都曾反思过这样一个事实：如果你看看西方的国家，看看他们在当时做的事情，中国正在推行这个庞大的考试计划。这非常不同。我不想在这个播客里抨击七国时代（Heptarchy）。我知道汤姆不会对满意的。那将是另一个棘手的争论。但许多写过这个话题的人都曾反思过，当中国在引入一种考试制度的同时，在英格兰，你却有七国时代，正如我所说，在大多数播客中，人们可能会说这反映了七国时代的糟糕，
but I don't want to say that. You can't come on this podcast and be reading in English accents. That's very poor. So I think also the exams, these exams in China, they're in classical Chinese and they're on the Confucian classics, and classical Chinese is not the vernacular. So for everyone who's studying them, they're having to learn another language almost. I suppose it's a bit like, you could say it probably is a bit like Latin in medieval Europe. It's really interesting. It's a language that kind of isn't a vernacular, but serves
但我不想这么说。你不能带着英国口音来参加这个播客。这太糟糕了。所以我也认为考试，中国的这些考试，它们是用文言文进行的，考的是儒家经典，而文言文并不是白话文。因此，对于每个学习它们的人来说，他们几乎不得不学习另一种语言。我想这有点像，你可以说它可能有点像中世纪欧洲的拉丁语。这真的很有趣。它是一种不是白话文，但起到
to maybe unite lots of different vernaculars. So as a kind of nation building, a sort of nation building system, it probably has that in common. And you're right, it's not something that the sort of Chinese peasants are doing, but the numbers do get up to being pretty big. I mean, certainly, you know, if we fast forward a bit, but by the 19th century, you are looking at two or three million kind of sitting the basic exams. Two or three million people. There's several stages of exams. There's a couple of different stages. There's like a basic local one.
将许多不同的白话文团结起来的作用的语言。因此，作为一种国家建设、一种国家建设的体系，它可能确实有这方面的共同点。你说得对，这不是中国农民在做的事情，但人数确实变得相当多。我的意思是，当然，你知道，如果我们把时间快进一点，到了19世纪，你就会看到两三百万人参加基础考试。两三百万人。考试有好几个阶段。有几个不同的阶段。就像一个基础的地方考试。
Then there's an intermediate. And then there's the palace exams, which are the kind of top, top, top ones to become the kind of top mandarins. And in terms of people starting out at the basic, the basic ones, yeah, you know, it gets into the millions. Obviously by the mid 19th century,
然后是中级考试。然后是殿试，这是成为顶级“满大人”的顶级、顶级、顶级考试。就从基础考试开始的人数而言，是的，你知道，人数达到了数百万。显然到了19世纪中叶，
the population of China is 350 million. Of those millions who are taking them, how many kind of, well, so how many get past exams and get places and how many reach the absolute top? So this is where it gets really interesting. So for anyone sort of struggling, thinking about maybe not getting their first choice exam at a university place now, or if they have got your first choice university place, the system over time got increasingly, increasingly harder to get these top spots. And in fact, lots of people have kind of implicated the failure of the exam system to reform and kind of provide more roles as one of the factors in particular the King dynasty in the 19th century, in, in, in some of its troubles and its downfall, because again, by the mid 19th century, you're looking at maybe two or 3 million people kind of setting out on that journey,
中国的人口是3.5亿。在参加考试的数百万人口中，有多少人能够，好吧，有多少人通过了考试并获得了名额，又有多少人达到了绝对的顶峰？所以这就是事情变得非常有趣的地方。所以对于任何苦苦挣扎、考虑现在可能考不上大学第一志愿，或者如果你考上了大学第一志愿的人来说，这个系统随着时间的推移变得越来越难获得这些顶级名额。事实上，许多人认为，考试系统未能进行改革并提供更多的职位，是19世纪清朝陷入困境和最终垮台的因素之一，因为同样，到19世纪中叶，你会看到大约两三百万人在踏上这段旅程，
trying to do those basic exams, but the very, very top roles, uh, you're looking at perhaps, you know, um, it's, it's, it's, I think on average, it averages out about maybe like a couple of hundred. Okay. Um, and then the, the, you know, leave the top jobs aside for a minute, even the intermediate ones. So if you pass one of the intermediate exams, you can still get a kind of civil service role. But what's interesting is those numbers don't really increase over time and keep pace with China's population. So what you're looking at is, as I say i think the population mid-19th century is about 350 million and the number of kind of you know civil service jobs available there is about half a million but that hasn't increased in a couple of hundred years um even as the population's increasing
试图参加那些基础考试，但非常、非常高层的职位，呃，你可能会看到，你知道，呃，这，这，这，我认为平均下来大概只有几百人。好的。呃，然后，你知道，先把高层的工作放在一边，甚至是中级考试。如果你通过了中级考试之一，你仍然可以获得某种公务员职位。但有趣的是，这些数字随着时间的推移并没有真正的增长，也没有跟上中国人口的增长。所以你看，正如我所说，我认为19世纪中叶的人口约为3.5亿，而那里可用的公务员工作岗位数量约为50万，但这在几百年里并没有增加，
the people are going for increasing so you're getting more and more people uh taking these exams uh more and more people kind of studying, spending, and they're hard exams. You know, you've got to learn all these classical Chinese characters. You've really got to start from a very young age. You've got to put a lot of time and effort into it. And yet the numbers, you know, the numbers of jobs you're getting are fixed and are not really going up. So there's kind of increasing pressure on the system. And that's classic kind of revolutionary material, isn't it? Overeducated, disaffected middle-class kids. I mean, they're the revolutionaries down the ages.
尽管人口在不断增加，
Absolutely. So I think this is where it gets really interesting, really interesting parallels with today. So, you know, there's really interesting stuff being written at the moment by Peter Turchin, who has this quite statistical approach to history. And his argument is that you can pick out, and I don't know whether you guys are like this or not but you can pick out some kind of key metrics uh statistics over history and use those to predict revolution and his argument is that the most important metric i think he picks out like three or four but one of the most important i think he says even the most
绝对的。所以我觉得这才是真正有趣的地方，与今天有着非常有趣的相似之处。所以，你知道，彼得·图尔钦（Peter Turchin）最近写了一些非常有趣的文章，他有一种相当统计学的方法来历史。他的论点是，你可以挑选出——我不知道你们是不是这样——但你可以挑选出历史上的某些关键指标、统计数据，并利用它们来预测革命，而他的论点是，最重要的指标——我想他挑选了三四个，但其中一个最重要的，我想他甚至说是最
important is um what he calls elite overproduction so the idea that you've got some systems in your society that are generating people with elite education elite aspirations but there aren't enough elite kind of roles or jobs for them to go into and he talks about modern america as an example that the number of senators has kind of stayed constant even as he's one of his favourite graphs is the number of law graduates that has really exploded. And I think China is definitely a kind of parallel here, China in the 19th century, that you've got this civil service, you know, sort of almost fixed number of roles, but you've got more and more people with that education maybe expecting that they
重要的——是，呃，他所谓的“精英过剩”（elite overproduction），也就是这样一种想法：你的社会中有些系统正在源源不断地培养出具有精英教育和精英抱负的人，但却没有足够的精英层面的职位或工作供他们去从事。他以现代美国为例，参议员的数量保持不变，而他最喜欢的图表之一就是法律专业毕业生的数量真正呈爆炸式增长。我认为中国在这里绝对是一个对照，19世纪的中国，你有这个公务员制度，你知道，职位数量几乎是固定的，但你有越来越多受过这种教育的人，可能期望自己
should get one of those and they are well educated they have studied for a long time they do have this knowledge of the Confucian classics and you know the jobs aren't there for them so so yeah really interesting to think of it in that light. So Daisy the people who study for these exams are they often the children themselves of civil servants? Because that's a kind of a feature of today, isn't it? That people who go to elite universities meet other people from elite universities and produce children who then go to elite universities. And so it perpetuates itself down the generations. So, again, some debate about this and again, lots of parallels with where we are. So there also seems to be the suggestion that over time, the kind of social mix of people get winning, you know, passing the exams know earlier on in the system the sort of 13th 14th century actually you do get a fair spread of of people from different different you know sort of different
应该得到其中一个职位，而且他们受过良好教育，学习了很长时间，确实拥有这些儒家经典的知识，但工作并不适合他们，所以，是的，从这个角度来思考真的很有趣。那么黛西，学习这些考试的人，他们通常是公务员自己的孩子吗？因为这就像是今天的一个特征，不是吗？进入精英大学的人会遇到其他来自精英大学的人，并生下以后也会进入精英大学的孩子。因此，这种情况一代又一代地延续下去。所以，同样，关于这一点有一些争论，也与我们现在的处境有很多相似之处。所以似乎也有这样一种暗示：随着时间的推移，获胜者的社会构成，也就是通过考试的人，在系统的早期——大约13、14世纪——实际上你确实得到了来自不同背景的人的相当广泛的分布，
different backgrounds whereas it really then starts to narrow and it does tend to be perhaps something it becomes a bit more of a you know hoops to be jumped through and people who kind of know the secrets and can can work out a way way to pass there's simply some some sort of suggestion uh around that that yeah the backgrounds people know they even have quotas regional quotas to to ensure that one region doesn't dominate uh yeah absolutely it's it's fascinating uh kind of how many parallels there are that it's such a long time ago and a different culture but i think so many so many similarities with i think what anyone working in exams in this country would really recognize there the most, the guy who has the worst exam result with the most consequences in history.
而之后它真正开始缩小，而且往往确实变成了某种，你知道的，需要跳过去的圈套，那些知道秘密并能找到通过方法的人。关于这一点确实有一些暗示，是的，人们的背景……他们甚至有区域配额，以确保没有一个区域占主导地位——是的，绝对的，这太迷人了，有这么多的相似之处，尽管那是很久以前的事了，文化也不同，但我认为有太多的相似之处，我想这个国家任何从事考试工作的人都会真正认同这一点——历史上面试结果最糟糕、后果最严重的人。
Yeah, we can't do this without mentioning Hong Zhukan. I think you've got to mention him if we've talked about the elite overproduction and exam failures and what happens there. So who's he? So he is, he's a kind of mid-19th century exam taker. He's one of the exam takers we talked about. And the other thing I failed to mention is, another thing that might make you feel grateful today is,
是的，我们不能不提洪秀全就谈这个。如果我们讨论过精英过剩、考试失败以及随之发生的事情，我想你必须提到他。那么他是谁？所以他是一个19世纪中期的应试者。他是我们讨论过的那些应试者之一。我漏掉的另一件事是，另一件可能会让你今天感到庆幸的事情是，
in China, it's not like you take these exams at 16 or 18, you fail and it's like, oh, just move on with your life. You can keep taking them again and again and again. And people do keep taking them again and again and again. And there's people who go on into their 40s, 50s, 60s, you know, they keep retaking them. And Hong Zhikan is one of these guys he's family of investment education in his kind of first round of local exams he comes first but then he gets
在中国，并不是说你在16岁或18岁时参加这些考试，失败了就像是，哦，继续你的生活吧。你可以一次又一次、一次又一次地不断参加考试。人们确实不断地一次又一次、一次又一次地参加。有的人到了40多岁、50多岁、60多岁，你知道，他们还在不断重考。而洪秀全就是这些人中的一员。他的家族为教育投资，在他的第一轮地方考试中他名列前茅，但随后他进入了这些后面的阶段，他考得没那么好，他失败了四次。好吧，所以他连续四次在那个下一步失败了——那个能让你得到工作的步骤。在这期间，他接触到了基督教，当时中国有许多美国传教士，所以他接触到了基督教，读了一些小册子，我想当他第四次考试失败时，他有了这个异象，这让他确信自己是基督的弟弟。
onto these later stages and he doesn't do as well and he fails them four times okay so he fails that kind of next step four times that step to kind of get you the the job and over this time he's been introduced to christianity there's a lot of american missionaries in china at that time so he's been introduced to christianity read some pamphlets and i think when he fails the the exam for the fourth time he has this vision which convinced him he's the younger brother of christ ah it's the typing rebellion yeah it's a typing rebellion yeah um and he inspires a number of people to follow him it's a typing rebellion which i think actually nowadays people say maybe it should be called a typing revolution or typing civil war. I think rebellion in many ways underplays it.
啊，太平天国起义，是的，太平天国起义，是的，嗯，他激励了许多人跟随他。这是一场太平天国起义，我想现在人们说也许它应该被称为太平天国革命或太平天国内战。我认为在许多方面用“起义”来形容都低估了它。
It's astonishing. It's, you know, it's I think between 1850, 1864, about between 30 and 50 million people die. And when it's most powerful, you know, he is running the typing heavenly kingdom, which rules over 30 million people. It's got a capital and it actually has the trappings of a state itself including it seems examinations um so uh examinations not yeah examinations not not of the Confucian classics but of a translation of the bible that he's made right this is a gift to you Tom Christianity finding its way even into exams absolutely well I was that's why i wanted to ask about it but i mean for anyone i mean anyone kind of you know failing their a levels that's that's quite a path to go isn't it yes slaughter millions killing 50 million people yes um do you think um so so this influence is
这太惊人了。你知道，我认为在1850年到1864年间，大约有3000万到5000万人死亡。当它最强大时，你知道，他统治着太平天国，统治着3000万人。它有一个首都，并且实际上具备了国家的特征，甚至似乎还包括考试——所以，呃，考试，不是，是的，考试，考的不是儒家经典，而是他翻译的圣经，对吧？这是给你的礼物，汤姆。基督教甚至找到了进入考试的途径。绝对的，好吧，我当时……这就是为什么我想问这件事，但对任何人来说——我的意思是，任何在A-Level考试中不及格的人——那真是一条漫长的道路，对吧？是的，屠杀数百万人，杀死5000万人，是的。嗯，你认为，嗯——所以这影响了
presumably the west you you said that Should we take a break now? And then when we come back, look at the evolution of the exam system in the West. Would that be a good plan? Sounds good to me. So if you'd like to stop writing, please, lay down your pens and we'll give you your second paper in about three minutes.
西方吗？你刚才说……我们现在休息一下好吗？然后等我们回来，看看西方考试制度的演变。这会是个好计划吗？听起来不错。所以如果你想停止写作，请放下你的笔，我们大约三分钟后发第二份试卷。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The exam starts in a couple of minutes. Pens at the ready, please. We are going to be talking about exams in the West. So Daisy, your first question. What about monks and things like that? So presumably they had tests of some i mean there must have been some sense of a test before the gladstonian reforms of the 19th century
以及抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。考试将在几分钟后开始。请准备好笔。我们将讨论西方的考试。所以黛西，你的第一个问题。关于僧侣之类的人呢？所以他们大概有某种测试——我的意思是，在19世纪格莱斯顿改革之前，一定某种意义上的测试吧？
so i think the big thing the sort of medieval religious kind of equivalent is um they have the disputatio disputation medieval disputation where you're having monks who have uh kind of these big kind of oral arguments with each other about big theological questions and I think that's probably the forerunner of today's viva and things like that as I say I think what you kind of lack in the west before the sort of 18th 19th century is anything that's really kind of standardized anything that's that's and not just standardized but also in this way the China thing comes in it's scalable so people even nowadays like the idea of a viva and i think back in the 19th century when the royal society of arts was coming up with um its its exams they
所以我觉得最重要的事情，中世纪宗教层面的等同物是，呃，他们有“辩论”（disputatio），中世纪的经院辩论，僧侣们会就重大的神学问题彼此进行大型的口头辩论，我认为这很可能是当今毕业论文答辩（viva）之类的先驱。正如我所说，我认为你在18世纪、19世纪之前的西方所缺乏的是任何真正标准化、任何——不仅标准化，而且以这种方式引入中国因素的东西——它是可扩展的（scalable）。所以即使在今天，人们也喜欢答辩的想法，我想在19世纪，当皇家艺术学会提出
said well these written exams are good but to be really sure the results are right you would also want to call the students in for a viva you know if you want to talk to them and this is again one of the challenges and it's again one of the challenges china had it's one of the challenges that exam people in exams today have you know my day job is something we do all the time that what do you do when you want to scale up so you can definitely see how having a viva might be the best way of doing something so daisy just for listeners who are not british yeah not familiar with the term what's what is a viva so i think nowadays you have them for phds and you would you know it's where you're having basically a kind of an oral interview so you've got um maybe a panel of people who are experts in the subject you've maybe written your
它的考试时，他们说，嗯，这些笔试很好，但为了真正确保结果正确，你还想把学生叫来参加答辩（viva），你知道，如果你想和他们交谈的话。这再次是挑战之一，也是中国曾面临的挑战之一，是今天从事考试工作的人所面临的挑战之一，你知道，我的日常工作就是我们一直在做的事情。当你想要扩大规模时该怎么办？所以你绝对可以看出，进行答辩可能是做某事最好的方式。所以黛西，为了那些不是英国人、对这个术语不熟悉的听众，什么是答辩（viva）？所以我认为现在你在攻读博士学位时会有这种考试，你知道，这基本上是一种口头面试，所以你有一个由该领域专家组成的小组，你可能已经写好了
dissertation you've written your essay and you're being questioned on it in depth and so if you want to do something that's as i say really really in-depth and thorough and it's very hard to cheat on, that's the thing people say about Vivas as well, quite hard to cheat, not impossible, but hard to cheat, then they kind of feel like a real gold standard. But they're very hard to scale up, obviously. And also, they are even, you know, they have their benefits. They're still kind of hard to standardize. And one of the things, you know, one of the tensions, as I say,
你的论文，你写好了文章，然后他们会就此对你进行深入的提问。所以如果你想做一些我刚才说的真正深入、透彻、而且很难作弊的事情——人们也是这么评价答辩的，很难作弊，并非不可能，但很难作弊——那么它们就会让人觉得像真正的黄金标准。但很显然，它们很难扩大规模。而且，它们甚至，你知道，它们有它们的好处，但它们仍然很难标准化。而其中的一个矛盾，正如我所说，
running all the way through the whole history of exams China, US, UK is this issue of standardization and reliability and consistency and it pulls you in different directions so in China they have this essay that's called the eight-legged essay and it's an essay that it's really set out really strictly kind of what you have to write in each bit. So it's got these eight parts. And over time, it just becomes quite pedantic and a bit of a hoop to jump through. And it's so similar when you read the critiques of it, the critiques people have today of exams that are very nitpicky and rubrics are very nitpicky. And, you know, actually, the history GCSE exam is often one that really comes in for this kind of criticism of if you don't use the word significance or bias, you just can't get
贯穿整个中国、美国、英国考试历史的始终，就是标准化、可靠性和一致性这一问题，它把人们拉向不同的方向。所以在中国，他们有这种叫做“八股文”的文章，这是一篇对你必须在每个部分写什么做出非常严格规定的文章。所以它有这八个部分。随着时间的推移，它变得相当学究气，有点像一个要跳过去的圈套。当你读到对它的批评时，它是如此相似——人们今天对那些非常挑剔、评分标准非常挑剔的考试的批评。而且，你知道，事实上，历史GCSE考试经常是真正受到这种批评的考试之一：如果你不使用“意义”（significance）或“偏见”（bias）这个词，你就拿不到
the mark. Whereas if you use the word significance, you get the mark, but people will say, you know, you could have written nonsense. Well, as I say, this is a debate that's going back a really long way. You know, to what extent, how standardized you have to be to get the reliability. And if you have, you know, too far down that route, do you sacrifice kind of the meaning or in the technical terms, do you sacrifice the validity of the exam? So how do exams start to be introduced into, is it Germany that blazes the trail?
分数。而如果你使用了“意义”这个词，你就得分了，但人们会说，你知道，你写的东西可能完全是废话。好吧，正如我所说，这是一个可以追溯到很久以前的辩论。你知道，在什么程度上，你必须多么标准化才能获得可靠性。如果你在这条路上走得太远，你是否会牺牲意义，或者用专业术语来说，你是否会牺牲考试的有效性（validity）？那么考试是如何开始被引入的呢？是德国开辟了先河吗？
So again, yeah, Germany, they introduce, actually it's Prussia. So it's Prussia. So in 1788, they introduced the abitur and that's a kind of exam that's required for university entrance and that's still used today and then again not only uh lots of people in britain looking at china but they're very much looking at prussia so prussia state reforms at this moment are having a really big impact in in in the uk and in fact um it's not just kind of the the school exams that are having a big impact but prussia i think after the you know skip forward a century after the um franco-prussian war
所以同样，是的，德国，他们引入了——其实是普鲁士。所以是普鲁士。在1788年，他们引入了“阿比图尔”（Abitur），这是一种大学入学考试，至今仍在使用。然后同样，不仅许多英国人关注中国，他们也非常关注普鲁士。所以普鲁士此时的国家改革在英国产生了非常大的影响。事实上，不仅仅是学校考试产生了巨大影响，普鲁士，我想在……跳过一个世纪后，在1870年的普法战争之后，甚至在此之前，许多英国人就一直在审视普鲁士军队，审视英国军队，心想：“等等。”因此，普鲁士不仅在1788年有了学校考试，他们的职业军队也鼓励英国人废除军队中的买官制（purchase of commissions）。我们当时正在进行我们的雕像漫步，汤姆，当我们遇到反对这一切的剑桥公爵时——是的，不，他说——所以是的，在19世纪中叶存在着巨大的争议。因此，真正更倾向于废除它的人是加内特·沃尔斯利（Garnet Worsley）。
in 1870 even before then there's been a lot of british people looking at the prussian army looking at the british army thinking hang on a minute and so not only do prussia have the the school exam 1788 but they're also probably their professional army is something that encourages the British to get rid of the purchase of commissions in the army we were doing we we were doing our statue walk Tom when we came across the Duke of Cambridge who opposed all this yes no he said that so yeah there's a huge controversy in the mid-19th century so the the guy who's really more in favor of them of getting rid of them is Garnet Worsley.
他是19世纪60年代末、1870年代初Cardwell改革背后的关键人物之一。他非常认为，你知道，你需要将军队招聘专业化，买官制必须废除。所以我认为买官制确实在1871年被废除了。而沃尔斯利在吉尔伯特和沙利文的《现代模范少将》（Model of a Modern Major General）中被讽刺了。如果你还记得《现代模范少将》的歌词，它是关于一个对各种事情了如指掌的将军，你知道的，关于正方形、斜边等 Facts（事实），诸如此类。而且，你知道，这是以沃尔斯利为原型的，
And he's kind of one of the figures behind the Cardwell reforms of, again, sort of late 1860s, early 1870s. He very much thinks, you know, you need to professionalise army recruitment, the Purchase of Commissions, it's got to go. So I think the Purchase of Commissions does go in 1871. And Worsley is satirised in Gilbert and Sullivan's Model of a Modern Major General. And if you remember the lyrics of the Model of a Modern Major General, it's about this general who knows this fantastic amount of stuff, you know, the facts about the square, the hypotenuse, that kind of thing. And, you know, it's based on Walsley,
他非常热衷于专业化，并为军官进行更正式的招聘和教育，而不仅仅是让人买官。所以，是的，你明白了。这是贯穿整个19世纪的一个真正的主题，无论是在军队还是在教育领域。黛西，考试完全关乎这一点。我的意思是，你需要一个国家，对吧？这一切都关乎国家权力并强加一种均一性，对吧？而且，你知道，你需要中心有某个人来决定人们需要学习什么以及他们需要接受什么评估。你需要一套机构来推广它。你需要每个人都买账并加入同一个系统。所以这非常有趣：你可以认为，实际上在英格兰，也许你并不需要。因此，真正有趣的事情不仅在于考试，还在于19世纪整个英国教育系统，它的中央集权化非常、非常晚。你很晚才获得国家层面的教育监督和国家资助。
who was very keen on professionalising and having more formal recruitment and education for army officers and not just having people buying commissions. So, yeah, you've got it. It's a real theme throughout the 19th century, both with the army and in education. And Daisy, exams are all about this. I mean, you need a state, don't you? It's all about state power and imposing a kind of uniformity, isn't it? And sort of, you need somebody at the centre who decides what it is that people need to study and what they need to be assessed on. You need an apparatus to roll it out. You need everyone buying into the same system. So this is what's really interesting is that you could argue that actually in England, maybe you don't. And so the really interesting thing, not just about exams, but the whole English education system in the 19th century is it centralises very, very late. You get central kind of state oversight and state funding of education generally very late.
这是因为宗教。这不是因为缺乏意愿。许多不同的群体都有意愿。但阻碍它的原因是，国家介入得太晚了，你有许多不同的宗教群体一直在资助他们自己的学校、他们自己的考试。所以，你知道，人们有一种不愿意的态度，那就是：“好吧，如果你要投入纳税人的资金，那么我是个不信奉国教者（nonconformist）。这意味着我的税钱要流向天主教教会。我对这很不满意。”甚至直到20世纪40年代，巴特勒法案（Butler Act）的批评者仍在反对，他们使用的短语是：“这是税收资助的罗马（Rome on the rates）。”好吧，那已经是20世纪40年代了，所以这实际上是我认为——你知道的，再次强调——为什么在英格兰，人们现在经常看到我们有所有这些不同的考试局，而且经常，你知道，我会和英国系统之外的人交谈，他们说：“这太疯狂了！你怎么能有所有这些不同的考试局？”我想甚至迈克尔·戈夫（Michael Gove）在担任教育大臣时也对此感到有点不高兴，认为这导致了水平下降，走向平庸的竞争。但我们拥有所有这些不同的考试局的原因，某种程度上是那种历史遗产。约翰·斯图尔特·密尔（John Strickland）也在《论自由》中谈到了这一点。他是另一个真正赞成、极力赞成教育、极力赞成考试的人，但因为他也赞成自由，所以他对国家强加考试、强加课程、强加学校持极其谨慎的态度，他想出了各种绕过这一问题的方法，无论是在资金方面——你知道的，《论自由》这本书花了很多时间讨论如何在没有暴政的情况下获得教育和教育资金——因此，这带来的遗产之一就是，你仍然拥有19世纪涌现的所有这些地方考试局的残余。而你所拥有的，还有，呃，许多大学。所以你刚才说——“它需要一个国家吗？”——好吧，第一批，你知道，许多英国人认为是第一批大考的东西，实际上是在1858年由
And that's because of religion. That's not because there isn't a will. There is a will from a lot of different groups. But the thing stopping it is that almost the state comes along too late and you've got a lot of different religious groups who have been self-funding their own schools, their own exams. And so, you know, there's this reluctance to say, well, if you're going to put taxpayer funding in it, then I'm a nonconformist. And that means that my tax money is going to go to the Catholic Church. I'm not happy about that. And even as late as the 1940s, you've critics of the butler act who are objecting and the phrase they use is it's rome on the rates okay and that's as late as the 1940s so that is actually one of the reasons i think you know sort of again why in england people often look now at the fact we've got all these different exam boards and often you know i'll talk to sort of people from outside the english system say this
牛津大学和剑桥大学设立的。它们被称为地方考试，是为不属于大学的学生、为16岁和18岁的年轻人设立的，这样他们就可以获得证书来证明他们学过什么。所以实际上在英格兰，你知道，你并没有那种你可能会想的那种国家在运行它的方式。但在1858年之前，人们是怎么进入牛津和剑桥的？所以你会去，你知道，哈罗公学、伊顿公学或其他什么学校，或者是拉格尔。这只是，你知道的……所以从我所看到的来看，它有点——再次强调——非常英国化，有点临时的、有点东拼西凑的。你有，你知道，与某些学校有特定联系的学院，它们会为这些学校保留特定的名额。
is mad how can you have all these different exam boards? And I think even Michael Gove, when he was education minister, was a bit unhappy about it and felt it was leading to dumbing down, a race to the bottom. But the reason we have all these different exam boards is kind of a legacy of that. And John Strickland also talked about this on Liberty. He's another person who's really in favour, massively in favour of education, massively in favor of exams but because he's also in favor of liberty he's really wary about the state imposing exams imposing a curriculum imposing schools and he comes up with all these ways around it both in terms of the funding you know it's a book on liberty spends a lot of time talking about how you're going to get education and funding of education without tyranny um and so one of the legacies of this is you do have still kind of the remnants of all these local exam boards that sprung up in the 19th century and what you also had is um lots of universities so you're saying like does it need a state well the first you know the thing that a lot of people in england think of as the first big exams were actually set in 1858 by
太疯狂了，怎么会有这么多不同的考试局？我觉得甚至迈克尔·戈夫担任教育大臣时也有点不高兴，他觉得这会导致水平下降、恶性竞争。但我们有这么多不同的考试局，某种程度上是历史遗留问题。约翰·斯特里克兰在《自由》节目中也谈到了这一点。他是另一个非常支持、极其支持教育、极其支持考试的人，但因为他也支持自由，所以他非常警惕国家强加考试、强加课程、强加学校，他想出了各种各样绕过这些的方法，无论是在资金方面——你知道，这是一本关于自由的书，花了很多时间讨论如何在没有暴政的情况下获得教育和教育资金——嗯，所以其中的一个遗留问题是，你仍然拥有19世纪涌现的这些地方考试局的某种残余，你还拥有——嗯，很多大学，所以你说的是——它需要国家吗？好吧，你知道，许多英格兰人认为的第一次大考实际上是由以下机构在1858年设立的
oxford and cambridge and they were set they were called local exams and they were set for students who weren't part of the university for 16 and 18 year olds that they could have a certificate to show what they'd studied so actually in England you know you don't have the kind of state the state sort of running it in the way you might think but so before 1858 how how are people getting to Oxford and Cambridge so so you you go to a you know, a Harrow or Eton or whatever, or rugby. Is it just, you know, you... So from what I've seen, it's just a bit, again, it's a bit, it's very English, a bit ad hoc, a bit hodgepodge. You've got, you know, colleges that have certain links with certain schools and they will have certain places for them.
牛津大学和剑桥大学，它们被称为地方考试，是为不属于大学的16岁和18岁学生设立的，这样他们就可以获得一张证书来证明他们所学的内容。所以实际上在英格兰，你知道，你没有那种你可能认为由国家来运营的方式，但是在1858年之前，人们是如何进入牛津和剑桥的呢？所以，你会去哈罗公学、伊顿公学什么的，或者是拉格 rugby。是不是，你知道，你……据我所见，这有点，再次说明，这有点非常英格兰式，有点临时抱佛脚，有点大杂烩。你知道，有些学院与某些学校有特定的联系，他们会为他们保留特定的名额。
So you don't have to do an exam or anything. There are exams. So I think Trinity is the first Cambridge college to bring in exams exams i think they do bring them in in the 18th century so so yes you do have some examples of exams coming in earlier than that but you have still a lot of as i say sort of these interviews and these there's famous examples you don't know how true they are of you know the the the the lord of whoever's son turning up and the question on his interview is well how's your father and he gets in you know so this is what i'm saying about standardization you don't feel like the interviews are being run on a sort of standardized protocol with a rubric marks out of
所以你不需要参加考试什么的。确实有考试。所以我想三一学院是剑桥大学第一所引入考试的学院我想他们是在18世纪引入的所以是的，你会发现有些考试出现的时间比那还要早，但正如我所说，你仍然会有很多这种面试，还有一些著名的例子，你不知道它们的真实性如何，比如某个领主的儿子来参加面试，面试官问他的问题是“你父亲最近怎么样？”，然后他就被录取了，你知道的——所以这就是我一直在说的关于标准化的问题，你不会觉得这些面试是在某种标准化的协议下进行的，有评分细则，满分是
whatever um so i think the exams are coming in gradually and some colleges are bringing them in before others um but it's it's it's kind of patchy and ad hoc and and then and then not state not not centralized you start to get kind of london universities which are reacting against the oxbridge monopoly with its emphasis on classics and starting to kind of introduce science and absolutely and so they're pulling things like that idiocy idiocy yeah so the judgment around what you should study is also huge and so even when people say okay we'll have exams that doesn't end the debate because the debate is then well what should we have on the exams and you have
诸如此类，嗯——所以我觉得考试是在逐渐引入的，有些学院比其他学院更早引入，嗯，但这有点零星、临时，而且不是集中式的。你开始看到一些伦敦的大学，它们反对牛津和剑桥的垄断及其对古典学科的强调，并开始引入科学。绝对是这样，所以他们正在推行类似的东西，真是荒谬，荒谬，是的。因此，关于你应该学习什么的判断也至关重要，所以即使人们说“好吧，我们要举行考试”，这也不会结束争论，因为随之而来的争论是“那我们的考试应该考什么呢？”你会看到
the famous uh northcote trevelyan report um which is i think 1854 so again really similar to all the time all these things are happening and northcote trevelyan that's about entry to the civil service and that's all about how you know you've got there's too that's about entry to the civil service and that's all about how you know you've got there's too much nepotism in in civil service entry and how you need to put it on at this more professional recruitment basis and you need to have exams but that just opens up the kind of words well what should be on the exam and there's been a lot of modern critiques who said well in the end they you know they went too far down that route of classics and kind of not enough down the route of the sort of professional knowledge and training that you might need to be a good civil servant.
著名的诺斯科特-特里维廉报告，我想那是1854年的——所以同样地，所有这些事情发生的时间真的很接近。诺斯科特-特里维廉报告是关于文官队伍（公务员）准入的，这完全关乎于，你知道的，文官队伍准入中存在太多的裙带关系，以及你如何需要将其置于更专业的招聘基础上，你需要举行考试。但这只是引发了诸如“考试应该考什么”之类的问题，并且有很多现代评论家说，最终他们，你知道的，在古典学科这条路上走得太远了，而在你成为一名优秀的公务员可能需要的专业知识和培训这条路上走得远远不够。
You can't come on this podcast and talk about going too far down the route of classics to Tom Holland. But again, that mirrors what you see in China. Because in China, you know know the exams are the Chinese classical Chinese and the Confucian classics but that went well for several centuries it did it perhaps you know by the time it ends in 1904 1905 doesn't end particularly well yeah all right no point the bit when they collapse into rival warlords that didn't work so well it's a detail, a detail. And people are saying then in the 19th century,
你不能在这个播客上跟汤姆·霍兰德谈论在古典学科这条路上走得太远的话题。但话又说回来，这与你在中国看到的情况不谋而合。因为在中国，你知道的，考试内容是中国的古典汉语和儒家经典，但这套系统运行了几个世纪，效果确实不错。不过，也许当它在1904年、1905年结束时，结局并不是特别好，是的，好吧，当他们陷入争权夺利的军阀混战时，这就说不上有什么意义了，那套系统运转得并不好。这只是个细节，细节而已。当时在19世纪，人们纷纷表示：
you have a lot of Chinese reformers who are saying, we have to reform these examples, reform the content of what's on them. We need more science, we need more technology. And actually, weirdly, that ends up being the same thing that people are saying about the British Civil Service. And I think a lot of people would still make that critique now. They would say there's not enough of that. And there's a very interesting story as well about the, I think a lot of people would still make that critique now. They would say there's not enough of that. And there's a very interesting story as well about the, I think,
有许多中国改革派表示，我们必须改革这些考试，改革考试内容的构成。我们需要更多的科学，我们需要更多的技术。而实际上，奇怪的是，这最终成了人们对英国公务员制度的同一种评价。而且我认为直到现在，很多人仍然会提出那样的批评。他们会说，这类内容还不够多。关于这一点，还有一个非常有趣的故事，我想直到现在，很多人仍然会提出那样的批评。他们会说，这类内容还不够多。而且关于这一点，还有一个非常有趣的故事，我想
Haleybury, Haleybury College, which actually its full name, I think, is Haleybury and Imperial Service College, which is, I think, set up to recruit civil servants for the East India Company. Which Clement Attlee goes to, right? Clement Attlee. Absolutely. And there's a talk that actually it should also form the basis,
黑利伯瑞学院，它的全名我想是黑利伯瑞暨帝国服务学院，我想该学院的建立是为了东印度公司招募公务员。克莱门特·艾德礼也曾就读于此，对吧？克莱门特·艾德礼。完全正确。并且有传言说，实际上它也应该构成
what they did, they should form the basis of what you do to recruit for the British Civil Service. but i think that gets kind of that doesn't quite work out and you end up with something that's much more much more sort of classical classical literature classical languages you know something that's much more focused on that um so yeah the content you're absolutely right to say that the content of what's on exams is something that really is thought about and And Daisy, you mentioned 1858. Am I right in thinking you have something there, you have an exam paper? So I have in front of me.
他们所做的事情，应该构成你为英国公务员招聘所做事情的基础。但我想这并没有完全行得通，最终你得到的还是那种更偏向于古典文学、古典语言的东西，你知道的，一种更专注于这方面的东西。所以，是的，关于考试内容，你说的完全正确，考试考什么确实是人们深思熟虑的问题。戴西，你提到了1858年。我的理解没错的话，你那里有什么东西，你有一份考卷？所以，我面前正放着。
You see, listeners, how desperate Dominic is to be examined, to show off his knowledge. It's appalling. It's like he's eight years old in his school. Let's scrap the chat and get straight to the questions. Come on. So I have a facsimile. So, Daisy, I hope you heard that Dominic is volunteering for this. I'm going to send him a message. is yeah let's scrap the chat and get straight to the questions come on so i have so daisy i hope
听众朋友们，你们看多米尼克是多么渴望参加考试，好显摆他的知识。这太可怕了。这就像他在学校里才八岁一样。咱们别闲聊了，直接进入问题吧。来吧。所以，我有了一份传真件。所以，戴西，我希望你听到多米尼克是自愿参加的。我要给他发个消息。是啊，咱们别闲聊了，直接进入问题吧。来吧。所以，我有——所以，戴西，我希望
you heard that dominic is volunteering for this i'm i'm gonna say i think we should i think it should be competitive i think it should be competitive the loser bows out of the rest is history so i have a copy in front of me of the 1858 examination papers so these are the by the university of cambridge so these as i say are kind of the these these local exams they're set for for for students to sit in in their school in these local or these local centers they're set by the university of cambridge and marked by them um and it's sort of seen yeah as a sort of a bit of a landmark moment these are a really really really big moment in the history of exams in in england and uh they've all the subjects i'm just flicking through them.
你听到多米尼克是自愿参加这个的。我要说，我觉得我们应该——我觉得这应该是竞争性的。我觉得这应该是竞争性的。输的人退出，剩下的历史自有评说。所以，我面前有一份1858年考试卷的副本。这些是剑桥大学出的考卷——所以正如我所说，这些是某种——这些地方考试。它们是为学生在自己的学校里参加这些地方中心或这些地方中心的考试而设立的，由剑桥大学出题并由他们批改，嗯——这被看作是一个具有里程碑意义的时刻。在英格兰考试的历史上，这些真的是非常、非常、非常重大的时刻。而且所有的科目——我正在快速翻看它们。
We've got English composition. We've got English history, which again, Dominic, I'm sure you're going to be keen on. Yeah, I'd be confident. I'm very confident on English history. We've got geography. We've got Virgil. Geography.
我们有英语作文。我们有英国历史，同样地，多米尼克，我确信你一定会对这个感兴趣。是的，我会很有信心的。我对英国历史非常有信心。我们有地理。我们有维吉尔。地理。
We've got a paper on Virgil. I'm not doing Virgil. I wouldn't say that. We've got absolutely tons here. I will point out there's one interesting thing. I remember when I started teaching, I taught English. I used to be a teacher. And you notice that the exam papers would always really reflect what was in the news and I remember starting to teach in 2007 and all the all the students I think they'd written a kind of coursework essay on the smoking ban because the
我们有一份关于维吉尔的试卷。我不考维吉尔。我可不这么说。这里简直有堆山积海的内容。我要指出一个有趣的事情。我记得当我刚开始教书时，我教的是英语。我曾经是一名老师。你会注意到，考试试卷总是能真实地反映出新闻里正在发生的事情。我记得我是在2007年开始教书的，所有的学生——我想他们写过一篇关于禁烟令的课程论文，因为
smoking ban had just come in and so they were all giving their pros and cons of the smoking ban and what's really interesting is that that seems to just always been the case that you do that. So I've got here Wednesday, December 15th, 1858, English composition. So no smoking ban questions. But what's the first question? Give an account of the late Indian mutiny. Oh, I love that. I'd be well up for that. Don't do that one. I mean, that might take a bit of time, Dominic. Go on, Dominic. Give us a look at the Indian mutiny. I refer you to William Dalrymple's appearance on The Rest Is History just a few weeks ago.
禁烟令刚刚颁布，所以他们都在阐述禁烟令的利弊。而真正有趣的是，这种情况似乎一直都是如此。所以我这里有：1858年12月15日，星期三，英语作文。所以没有关于禁烟令的问题。但是第一个问题是什么？“请叙述近期的印度兵变。”哦，我喜欢那个。我完全可以应付那个。别选那个。我的意思是，那可能需要花点时间，多米尼克。来吧，多米尼克。给我们讲讲印度兵变。我请你们参考威廉·达尔林普尔几周前在《历史的休止符》节目中的亮相。
So you've got number two, contrast the life of a soldier with that of a sailor, both in peace and war. OK, that's good. That's a good one. That's quite broad. Number three, write a letter to a friend in Australia announcing your intention to emigrate and asking for information. I think that's so 1858. I just think that's so 1858. And finally, what do you think the fourth one is? Discuss the change produced in the habits of the people
所以第二题是：“对比士兵与水手的生活，无论是在和平时期还是在战争时期。”好吧，这很好。这是一个好问题。这相当广泛。第三题：“给在澳大利亚的朋友写一封信，宣布你打算移民并询问相关信息。”我认为这太1858年了。我只是觉得这太1858年了。最后，你认为第四题是什么？“讨论由铁路引起的
by railways. Oh, wow. That's a very typical. So the Australian one, I would do that. You know what I'd do? I'd write to Mr. McCorber. He would be my friend. He emigrated to Australia, didn't he? I'd write to him. Yeah?ber he would be my friend he's he emigrated to australia didn't
人们生活习惯的变化。”哦，哇。这是一个非常典型的题目。所以澳大利亚那个，我会选。你知道我会怎么做吗？我会写信给麦考伯先生。他会是我的朋友。他移民去了澳大利亚，不是吗？我会写信给他。是吗？伯，他会是我的朋友，他移民去了澳大利亚，不是吗？
he i'd write to him yeah i could tell him there's something you want to pick magwitch i would say something had turned up um i would i would ask him for repayment of the loan that i had made just before he left the country i've got it all planned and i'm sure if dickens was marking i'd do very well no f derivative so i would say the english composition probably hasn't changed that much in terms of it's a topical topic you've got to write you've got to find find something happening in the news right about it like i remember in 2012 everything seemed to be about the olympics you had to write something about the london olympics i looked up some from the 1950s and there's some then that are all about the festival of britain you know tell us what you
我会写信给他。是的，我可以告诉他，你有些东西想从马格韦奇那里拿回来，我会说有些事情已经有了转机，嗯，我会向他索还我在他离开这个国家之前借给他的贷款。我都计划好了，而且我相信如果是狄更斯来批卷的话，我会考得很好。不，太流于形式了。所以我想英语作文可能并没有发生太大的变化，就它是一个热门话题而言，你必须动笔写，你必须在新闻中找到正在发生的事情，然后围绕它写作。就像我记得在2012年，所有事情似乎都与奥运会有关，你必须写一些关于伦敦奥运会的内容。我查阅了一些20世纪50年代的试卷，发现那时有些题目完全是关于英国艺术节的，你知道的，告诉我们你
think about the festival of britain so that is actually one that maybe hasn't changed as much but some of the others i think have really changed um i think geography is very much um oxbow lakes do they have oxbow lakes i did no no there's no oxbow lakes i'm just looking at the geography paper and it's all drawing oh no so they've got explain the following geographical terms, but Hogsbow Lake is not one of them. But there's a lot of, you know,
对英国艺术节的看法。所以这实际上是一个可能没有太大改变的方面，但我认为其他一些方面确实发生了很大的变化，嗯，我认为地理非常——牛轭湖，它们有牛轭湖吗？我没有——不，没有牛轭湖，我只是在看地理试卷，全都是画图——哦，不，所以它们要求“解释以下地理术语”，但牛轭湖并不在其中。但有很多，你知道的，
where's, draw a map, where's this, where's that. You see, that's proper geography. That is geography. To me,
在哪里，画一张地图，这里是哪里，那里是哪里。你看，那是真正的地理。那才是地理。在我看来，
that's not outdated at all. That's completely reasonable. No, but geography's gone wrong now because it's all about, you know, dreary stuff that nobody, capital cities and flags.
那一点也不过时。那是完全合理的。不，但地理现在已经变味了，因为全都是那些没人感兴趣的枯燥东西，首都和国旗。
Draw an outline map showing the coastline of Europe from the mouth of the Danube to the mouth of the Rhine. Mark the chief rivers and the ranges of mountains between those two rivers and the coast. I think, you know, you have to submit your papers here. Describe accurately the situation of the following places. Genoa, Londonderry, Mecca, Rio de Janeiro, Singapore. Mecca. I mean, that's a controversial one. Describe in words the course
“画一张轮廓图，标出从多瑙河口到莱茵河口的欧洲海岸线。标出这两条河流之间的主要河流和山脉以及海岸。”我想，你知道的，你必须在这里提交你的试卷。“准确描述以下地点的地理位置：热那亚、伦敦德里、麦加、里约热内卢、新加坡。”麦加。我的意思是，这是一个有争议的用词。用文字描述以下其中一条河流的流向，
of one of the following rivers, mentioning the chief towns upon its banks. The Thames, the Severn, the Rhone, the Danube. This is why Victorian Britain was great. But these sort of questions... But these sort of questions endured for quite a long time though, didn't they? Because I've got here,
并提及沿岸的主要城镇：泰晤士河、塞文河、罗讷河、多瑙河。这就是为什么维多利亚时期的英国是伟大的。但这类问题……但这类问题确实持续了相当长的一段时间，不是吗？因为我这里有，
I downloaded overnight an exam paper from 1950, a history paper, right? So this is a Scottish leaving certificate exam. So kind of similar age group, I guess, Daisy. I was really wanting to ask Tom some of these questions. So question four, for example,
我昨天夜里下载了一份1950年的考试卷，一份历史试卷，对吧？所以这是一份苏格兰离校证书考试卷。所以年龄段差不多，我想，戴西。我真的很想问汤姆其中一些问题。比如第四题，
what changes did Henry VIII make in regard to the church and for what reasons? That's interesting. It's a Scottish question. That's such a massive question. Isn't it? Next question.
亨利八世对教会做出了哪些改变？原因是什么？这很有趣。这是一个苏格兰的问题。这是一个极其宏大的问题。不是吗？下一个问题。
I mean, how about this? Trace the chief steps in the development of South Africa from the Great Trek to the Union Act of 1909. How do you think you'd do with that, Tom? I might look at another question. What were the reasons for the collapse of Napoleon's empire? Yeah, I could do that. Could you do that?
我的意思是，这个呢？“追溯南非从大迁徙到1909年《联邦法案》的发展中的主要步骤。”汤姆，你觉得你能应付这个吗？我可能会看看别的题目。“拿破仑帝国崩溃的原因是什么？”是的，我能做到。你能做到吗？
Could you really do that? Overconfidence. Describe the domestic problems. And the glories of the British Navy. Describe the domestic problems that faced the British government from 1905 to 1914 and explain the measures they took to solve them you do that i could probably have a crack at that because i've listened to you on the causes of the first world war that's a strange death of liberal england isn't it suffragettes trade unionism ireland ireland yep and then here's one for ted valence
你真的能做到吗？过度自信。“描述英国政府在1905年至1914年间面临的国内问题，并解释他们为解决这些问题而采取的措施。”你能做到吗？我大概能试一试，因为我听过你讲第一次世界大战的起因。那是自由主义英国的奇异死亡，对吧？女性参政权论者、工会主义、爱尔兰、爱尔兰，是的。然后这里有一道题是给泰德·瓦伦斯的，
who we had on talking about magna carta outline the events in john's reign that led up to magna carta and explain briefly the importance of that document making sure to give the dates of king john's reign yeah well he didn't know so he would have done badly despite being a professor of history but what's interesting about that it's a scottish exam paper but so many english questions um so scottish listeners will say this is an example of the totalitarian you know yes so there's been a move away from that there has there has hasn't it and it's all kings and battles i mean this is 1950 so it's 1066 and all that i mean they parody that don't they well they do that's 1066 and all that the victorians would recognize that as completely
我们曾请他来谈论《大宪章》：“概述约翰国王统治时期导致《大宪章》出台的事件，并简要解释该文件的历史重要性，务必写明约翰国王统治的起止年份。”是的，嗯，他不知道，所以尽管他是一位历史教授，他还是会考得很糟。但关于那份试卷，有趣的是，它是一份苏格兰的考试卷，却有这么多的英国问题——所以苏格兰的听众会说，这是极权主义的一个例子，你知道的，是的——所以人们已经开始摆脱那种模式了，确实如此，确实如此，不是吗？全都是国王和战役。我的意思是，这是1950年，所以这是《1066和这一切》的风格，我的意思是，他们是在讽刺那个，不是吗？嗯，他们确实如此，那是《1066和这一切》。维多利亚时代的人会认为那完全是
reasonable but probably exams have changed far more in the intervening period in from then till now than they did in the hundred years previous do you think that's true daisy uh i would say yeah i think that probably is true yeah i think there's some truth to that so again i sort of spent a bit of time in the cambria assessment archive looking at the o levels in the 1950s um and again yeah the history if you compare them to the 1858 ones i think there are a lot of similarities um certainly the geography and the history are much more kind of lists of facts looking at that. So Daisy, I guess the argument, say, for example, of a Daily Mail columnist. Where could such a person be found?
合理的，但可能从那时到现在的这段时间里，考试发生的变化，远比之前那一百年里的变化还要大得多。你觉得是这样吗，戴西？呃，我会说是的，我想这大概是真的，是的。我想这其中有一定道理。所以同样地，我花了一些时间在剑桥考试档案库里查阅20世纪50年代的普通水准考试（O Level），嗯，同样是的，如果你把历史试卷与1858年的进行比较，我认为有很多相似之处，当然地理和历史试卷更像是各种事实的罗列，从试卷来看是这样的。所以戴西，我想，比如说，《每日邮报》专栏作家的论点会是什么？这样的人会在哪里找到？
Mentioning the name. But there is a kind of harumph every time GCSE A-level results come out that they're not as difficult as they used to be. Are you in a position? I know what Tom wants you to say. Everyone knows what Tom wants you to say, Daisy. Have exams got more difficult? Have they got easier?
提到这个名字。但每当普通中等教育证书（GCSE）和高级水平考试（A Level）成绩出来时，总会有这样的抱怨：现在的考试没有以前那么难了。你处于什么位置？我知道汤姆想让你说什么。每个人都知道汤姆想让你说什么，戴西。考试变得更难了吗？它们变得更容易了吗？
Are they basically the same? Can we measure them? This is a great question and one that I could probably spend an entire podcast on. It is really surprisingly hard to answer the question. And in fact, we've looked at exams really for a very kind of historical, political lens and educational lens. Another interesting way of looking at exams actually is as a branch of measurement. And there are actually some really interesting overlaps between, you like the development of the history of temperature um the measurement of temperature the measurement of time that there's actually some really interesting overlaps there but one of the the challenges with
它们基本上是一样的吗？我们能衡量它们吗？这是一个极好的问题，我大概可以为此花上一整期播客的时间。要回答这个问题，实际上出奇地困难。事实上，我们一直是从非常历史性、政治性的视角以及教育学的视角来看待考试。而看待考试的另一个有趣方式，其实是将其视为测量的分支。并且在——你喜欢温度历史的发展、温度的测量、时间的测量之间，实际上存在着一些非常有趣的重叠，那里实际上有一些非常有趣的重叠。但其中一个挑战在于
with with the measurement and trying to work out if standards have have have changed i'll say um is there's just a number of issues so so one is what we want to do is look at the questions, don't we, as we've just done and go, well, that question's really hard. There's a professor of history at the moment who couldn't answer that question. Ergo, exams are getting easier. But the big problem is you can't just look at the questions. I've got this whole book of questions. But how do you know that the kids who took them then actually, how do you know they didn't do really terribly how do you know actually they just left blank papers they didn't have a clue so we're all sitting here it's kind of rote learning isn't it i mean it's kind of rote learning
测量并试图弄清楚标准是否发生了变化，嗯，有很多问题。所以，一个是，我们想做的是看题目，正如我们刚刚所做的那样，然后说：“好吧，那个问题真的很难。当今的一位历史教授都回答不出那个问题。因此，考试变得越来越简单了。”但最大的问题是，你不能只看题目。我有整整一本这样的题目。但是你怎么知道当时参加考试的孩子们实际上——你怎么知道他们不是考得糟糕透顶？你怎么知道实际上他们只是交了白卷，根本一无所知？所以我们都坐在这里，这有点像死记硬背，不是吗？我的意思是，这有点像死记硬背
dates of kings and queens the next critique is is that the next critique so so first of all the first reason why it's hard is you can't just look at exam paper you need responses and we don't have enough responses that you have these archives of question papers but you don't have enough archives of responses. So that's one problem. The second problem is what you've just said, is that exams have really changed their focus. And so someone might look and say, well, okay, so a kid didn't do well on these questions about the dates of whatever. Someone might look at that and go, well, I don't care. I think history is more than that. So you might have a very talented history student today who wouldn't do well on that exam, but they're still better at history because our notion of what history is has changed. Now, I'm not sure how much I would buy that with
帝王将相的年代。下一个批判是这个吗？那是下一个批判吗？所以，首先，考试很难的第一个原因是你不能只看考卷，你需要考生的答卷，而我们没有足够多的答卷。你拥有这些试题档案，但你没有足够多的答卷档案。所以这是一个问题。第二个问题就是你刚刚所说的，考试确实改变了它们的侧重点。因此，有人可能会看一眼然后说：“好吧，所以一个孩子在这些关于什么的日期的题目上表现不好。”有人可能会看到这一点然后说：“好吧，我不在乎。我认为历史不仅仅是那样。”所以你今天可能会有一个非常有才华的历史系学生，他在那场考试中表现不会很好，但他仍然更擅长历史，因为我们对历史是什么的观念已经改变了。现在，我不确定在历史学科上我对这种说法的赞同程度有多高，
history, but I would probably buy it with other subjects. What we now call biology, which in here is probably more zoology, that's changed its focus. And I think entirely legitimately, I don't think anyone would argue with that because we just know more now. So the other problem is you've got subjects changing. That makes it harder to compare. And the other problem you've got is that these exams from the past are often aimed at a very different slice of pupils. So these exams of the past were often being taken by a fraction, a segment of the population. The modern GCSE is taken by everybody. Even the old O-level was only really been taken by 20, 25 segment of the population. The modern GCSE is taken by everybody. Even the old O-level has only really been taken by 20%, 25% of the cohort.
但我可能会在其他学科上认同这一点。我们现在所说的生物学——在这份试卷里可能更多是动物学——已经改变了它的侧重点。而且我认为完全合乎情理，我想没有人会反驳这一点，因为我们现在知道得更多了。所以另一个问题是，科目在不断变化，这使得比较变得更加困难。而你遇到的另一个问题是，过去这些考试的对象通常是截然不同的学生群体。因此，过去这些考试通常只有一小部分人口在参加。现代的GCSE是每个人都要参加的。即使是旧的O Level也真的只有20%、25%的人口在参加。现代的GCSE是每个人都要参加的。即使是旧的O Level也真的只有20%、25%的同龄人群体在参加。
And that changes the way you set up your grading. Yeah, because the process is so much broader. Right. So just imagine if you've got, you know, when you've got grades, you've maybe got five or 10 or nine or however many grades you've got to award. If you're going to award that grade set to the top 10 of the population it's going to look very different the top grade is going to be awarded to a very different fragment of people than if you're awarding a grade set to 100 of the population that's just going to happen yeah so you've got to factor all those things in so
这改变了你建立评分标准的方式。是的，因为考生范围要广泛得多。没错。所以试想一下，如果你有——你知道的，当你有了成绩时，你可能有五档、十档、九档或任意数量的成绩需要评定。如果你要把这套成绩评定给前10%的人口，它看起来会非常大不相同，最高分将被授予一个与你把一套成绩评定给100%的人口时完全不同的人群，这种情况就是会发生。是的，所以你必须把所有这些因素都考虑进去。所以
i'm getting all my excuses in up front but notwithstanding that you can do some interesting comparisons even with all of those caveats. And the person who carried out a really, really interesting study into this is actually a colleague of mine. And he used this technique I talked about, comparative judgment. So his name is Dr. Chris Whedon. And he did this paper back in 2016 with some colleagues. So it's not just him, a group of them. And what they were trying to address is the question. So to address one of these to, so to, to, to address one of these problems about exams changing their focus and content,
我把所有的借口都摆在前面了，但尽管如此，即使带上所有这些限定条件，你还是可以做出一些有趣的比较。而真正、真正深入研究这项研究的人，实际上是我的同事。他用了我刚才讲过的一种技术：比较判断。所以他的名字叫克里斯·韦登博士（Dr. Chris Whedon）。他在2016年与一些同事发表了一篇论文。所以不仅仅是他，还有他们的一群人。他们试图探讨的问题是：为了解决其中一个问题——为了解决关于考试改变其侧重点和内容的问题之一，
they picked a subject that hasn't changed as much. They picked a mathematics A level where you do have a bit more stability in, in the kind of questions being asked. And they also did have some archive responses and they use this technique, comparative judgment to compare the difficulty of the question and the responses over time. And they actually got maths phd students to judge it so it was students who kind of didn't know about the english system the students didn't know why they were taking part in this they didn't know that it was about standards over time so the really clever study
他们选择了一个没有发生太大变化的科目。他们选择了一个数学A Level，在这个科目中，所提问题的稳定性要稍微高一些。他们确实也有一些历史答卷存档，并且他们使用比较判断这种技术，来比较随着时间推移题目和答卷的难度。他们实际上找了数学博士生来评判它，所以这些学生对英国体制一无所知，这些学生甚至不知道他们为什么要参与其中，他们也不知道这与历年来的标准有关——所以这是一项非常巧妙的研究，
they set up and i will say now up front that it won the 2016 british educational research journal paper of the year so it's a really you know I'm not just saying because it's my colleague it's a really clever paper really well done and they were comparing maths a-level responses from 1964 1968 1996 and 2012 and they were saying have the standards has the stat have the standards changed and what they found was that between 1964 and 1968, there wasn't much change. Between 1996 and 2012, there wasn't much change. Between 1968 and 1996, they found the standard
他们进行了设计，我现在就可以提前说明，它赢得了2016年英国教育研究期刊年度最佳论文奖，所以这真的是——我这么说不仅仅因为他是我的同事，这真的是一篇非常巧妙的论文，做得非常好。他们比较了1964年、1968年、1996年和2012年的数学A Level答卷，他们想知道：标准，标准，标准是否发生了变化？他们发现，在1964年到1968年之间，没有太大变化。在1996年到2012年之间，没有太大变化。在1968年到1996年之间，他们发现那个标准是：
that would have received a grade E in 1968 would have got a grade B in 1996. Wow. That really surprises me. That's the punchline. Goodness. So I was expecting, because you were almost setting it up there, and I thought you were going to say,
在1968年只能得E等成绩的水平，到了1996年可以得B等。哇。这真的让我很吃惊。这就是妙语。天哪。所以我本来在期待——因为你当时几乎是在为此做铺垫，我以为你要说：
oh, this debunks the idea that things have changed. This shows that actually we're clever enough. But actually, that's a massive drop of standards, right? Right. Again, I do want to caveat it, is that over that same time, you had many more people sitting the A-level. And so, yes, I think it is fair to say grades have changed in meaning i think that is absolutely fair to say and i'd almost say you would expect that if you have that many more people kind of taking them but actually that doesn't necessarily mean that underlying attainment is is falling or rising it does mean the grade has changed its
哦，这驳斥了事物已经发生改变的观点。这表明实际上我们足够聪明。但实际上，这是标准的大幅下降，对吧？没错。再次强调，我确实想加一个限定条件，那就是在同一时期，参加A Level考试的人数要多得多。所以，是的，我认为说成绩的含义已经改变是公平的，我认为这绝对是公平的，我甚至可以说，如果有这么多人参加考试，你本就会预料到这一点。但这并不一定意味着潜在的学业成就正在下降或上升，它确实意味着成绩的含义已经
meaning right it doesn't mean we're getting stupid or cleverer it's not enough there to say that but it does mean the grade has changed in meaning but going back to specifically history um there's no doubt that what people study has changed you know very dramatically so looking at this paper that the 1950 paper and thinking about what i did at gcse because i was one of the earliest gcse. I mean, I can remember we got to do an empathy exercise. I mean, empathy was very big in our teaching. And, you know, I had to write a letter pretending that I was a housewife in Hamburg, explaining why I was going to support the Nazi party in 1933. And, you know, that's the kind of exercise that would have been
改变了，对吧？这并不意味着我们变得更蠢或更聪明了，单凭这一点还不足以说明问题，但它确实意味着成绩的含义已经改变了。但具体回到历史学科上来……毫无疑问，人们学习的内容已经发生了非常巨大的变化。所以看看这份1950年的试卷，回想一下我在GCSE时所学的内容，因为我是最早参加GCSE考试的人之一。我的意思是，我记得我们必须做一个同理心练习。我的意思是，同理心在我们的教学中非常重要。而且，你知道的，我不得不写一封信，假装我是汉堡的一名家庭主妇，解释为什么我要在1933年支持纳粹党。而且，你知道的，这种练习在1950年是不可想象的，更不用说在18——显然在19世纪60年代或更早了。我的意思是，所以你并没有真正——我的意思是，也许你在用数学进行同类比较。你在进行同类比较，但你绝对不是在用历史这样做，对吧？因为历史，历史内部的侧重点已经发生了如此巨大的变化。所以这绝对是进行这些比较的一个挑战所在。这就是为什么你可以对数学之类的学科这样做。
unthinkable in 1950, let alone 18, you know, obviously in the 1860s or something. I mean, so you're not really, I mean, maybe you are testing like with like with maths. You are comparing like with like, but you're definitely not doing that, are you, with history? Because history, the emphasis within history has changed so much. So that's absolutely why it's a challenge to make these comparisons. And that's why you can do it with something like maths.
正如我所说，我认为你也可以对英语作文（当时是这么叫的）这样做。而且我认为也有过一些尝试，用这种方法来对待写作标准，因为你所问的学科和问题并没有发生那么大的变化。但我认为你对于历史或地理之类的学科的看法是绝对正确的。那样会更困难。你会发现——是的，确实会。因为你所说的所有原因，那样会更加困难。而且不仅是历史，还有许多其他科目，你所评估的内容已经发生了巨大的变化。所以，戴西，我们的时间可能不多了，
As I say, I think you could do it with English composition, as they call it then. And I think there have been a few attempts to kind of do that as well with writing standards, because the subject, the question you're asking isn't changing as much. But I think you're absolutely right with something like history or geography. It would be more difficult. You would. Yeah, it would be. It would be more difficult because of all the reasons that you said. And again, not just history there'll be a number of other subjects where that the content of what you you're assessing has changed so much so so daisy um we're probably running out of time
而且考官要收走我们的试卷了，但是，由近期的事件引发的两个问题：一个是，你认为大流行的经历是加深了人们对考试价值的认识，还是让人对它产生了质疑？你认为当我们走出大流行时，体制会和2019年时一模一样吗？另一个问题是回到精英过剩的问题，不过也许可以先回答第一个问题，当然可以。
and uh the invigilator will take away our papers but um just two questions prompted by kind of recent events. One is, do you think the experience of the pandemic has sharpened people's sense of the value of exams or led them to question it? Do you think that the system will be the same as it was in 2019 when we come out of the pandemic? And the other one is just to go back to the question of elite overproduction but maybe just maybe the first one first sure so i think what you see here is i find there's quite an interesting division between people i would say who are kind of on the on the outside of education and people who are actually probably teachers and in the system which is that there have been quite a few calls i mean a group of education ministers former education ministers came together recently and said the pandemic's shown us that exams don't work and we need to abolish gcses now most of the teachers i talked to think the pandemic's shown you that exams for all their
当然。所以我想你在这里看到的——我发现人们之间存在着一个非常有趣的鸿沟，我指的是那些游离于教育体系之外的人，与那些实际上可能是教师并身处体制之内的人之间存在鸿沟。那就是有过相当多的呼吁——我的意思是，一群教育大臣、前教育大臣最近聚集在一起说：“大流行向我们表明考试行不通，我们需要现在就废除GCSE。”然而，我交谈过的大多数老师都认为大流行向你表明，尽管考试有种种
flaws are really necessary because the we've had two years without exams and i i can't imagine how you would look at that and say what we've had in those two years has been an improvement um it's been really messy. And I think the big issue you have is there's lots of legitimate critiques of exams. Absolutely, there are. And some of those, as I say, date back to China. The great problem you have when trying to replace them with anything, it's a bit like democracy. There's a lot of critiques of democracy at the moment. What are you going to do instead of them? And when you, all of the alternatives you come up with seem to have all the flaws of exams plus some new ones. So what you've seen this year and last year with the teacher assessment is the teacher assessment.
缺陷，但它们确实是必不可少的。因为我们已经经历了两年没有考试的日子，我无法想象你怎么能看着这一切然后说，这两年里我们所经历的是一种改进——那真的是一团糟。我认为你面临的巨大问题是，有很多对考试的合理解读。绝对的，确实有。而且其中一些，正如我所说，可以追溯到中国。当你试图用任何东西来取代它们时，你面临的巨大问题是——这有点像民主。目前对民主有很多批评。那你打算用什么来代替它们呢？当你提出所有的替代方案时，它们似乎既有考试的所有缺陷，又带有一些新的缺陷。所以今年和去年你在教师评估中看到的情况就是：教师评估。
Many issues with, I think, but one of the big issues you have with it is that poor students, disadvantaged students, students with behavioural issues, students with special educational needs all tend to do worse on teacher assessment than on exams and people are often really surprised when i say that they say no it's the other way around you're wrong it must be the other way around and it's not there's a a huge research body on this um and it's to do with similarly big research bodies on human bias and the thing i say teachers are biased not because they're bad people they're biased because they're human and and lots of things that involve human judgment do have those those biases built into them so as I say that's one of the the the the best evidence findings in in the assessment literature so that the the great problem you have if you want to rely on just the kind of pure teacher
我认为这里面有很多问题，但你面临的其中一个大问题是，表现较差的学生、处于弱势的学生、有行为问题的学生、有特殊教育需求的学生的表现，往往在教师评估中比在考试中更差。每当我这么说时，人们通常都会感到非常惊讶，他们会说：“不，情况正好相反，你错了，情况一定相反。”但事实并非如此，关于这一点有大量的研究机构（研究成果），而且有类似的大型研究机构专门研究人类偏见。我要说的是，老师带有偏见，不是因为他们是坏人，而是因为他们是人，并且许多涉及人类判断的事物都内在地带有这些偏见。正如我所说，这是评估文献中证据最确凿的发现之一。所以，如果你只想依赖过去两年中我们因必要性而采用的那种纯粹的教师
assessment we've had in these past two years as a we've had it because of necessity is that it doesn't really give you that level playing field and exams certainly have their problems and i'm not pretending that exams are the perfectly level playing field either but again it's i'd say of all the different alternatives they're the ones that are probably the best so i think there are lots of people who are saying well the pandemic shows that we've got to change things but my argument would be the pandemic shows us that when we can't run exams, we have real problems. So I would say I think we need them and I think we'll still be using them in years to come. And so just on the back of that, kind of looking at the broad context of what we've been talking about generally.
评估，你所面临的巨大问题是，它并没有真正为你提供一个公平的竞争环境。考试当然有它们的问题，我并不是假装考试是一个绝对公平的竞争环境，但再次强调，我要说的是，在所有不同的替代方案中，它们可能是最好的那种。所以我想有很多人在说：“大流行表明我们必须改变现状。”但我的论点是，大流行向我们表明，当我们无法举行考试时，我们就会遇到真正的问题。所以我想说，我们需要考试，并且我认为在未来的几年里我们仍将使用它们。因此，紧接着这一点，结合我们一直在讨论的总体广泛背景来看。
Do you think in the future that exams will serve the cause of social mobility or entrench existing divisions? So that is a great question. And it is hard to say. And as I say, I don't want to pretend that exams are perfect and that they are this perfect engine of social mobility. Again, I think it is really interesting to look back to China, where I think you can argue that there's a phase in their history where they probably were working as you would want them to work. And then there was a phase where they weren't. And I think you can see something similar probably in the modern Western system of exams that you can see there are ways where they do work as they're meant to there are ways where they don't um i i think there are real issues around the content of what should be on exams and whether what is on exams is preparing students for
你认为未来考试是会为社会流动性的事业服务，还是会巩固现有的阶层划分？这是一个极好的问题。而且很难说。正如我所说，我不想假装考试是完美的，也不想假装它们是促进社会流动性的完美引擎。同样，我认为回顾中国历史真的很有趣，我认为你可以辩称，在他们历史的某个阶段，考试的运作方式可能正是你所希望的那样。然后是另一个它们没有发挥作用的阶段。我想你大概可以在现代西方考试制度中看到类似的情况，你可以看到，在某些方面它们确实如预期般运作，而在另一些方面它们没有。我认为在考试应该考什么内容方面，以及考试内容是否在为学生做准备方面，确实存在真正的问题。
the world i think that's absolutely legitimate question so i think that you want reform of that that seems to me it can be sensible i think the other um big issue you have as well is um yeah i think there is an issue around if they do just become if you like box ticking hoop jumping exercises and i think if you do get too much almost kind of over reliance on rubrics i think that can decay confidence in them. And I think that also means they're probably not doing their job of actually giving students the knowledge and skills they need to get by in the world. So they become almost something that's separate from the education.
我认为这是一个绝对合理的问题。所以我想你会希望对此进行改革，这在我看来是明智的。我认为你遇到的另一个重大问题是——是的，我认为如果它们仅仅变成——如果你愿意的话——勾选框、跳圈子的练习，就会存在一个问题。而且我认为，如果你对评分细则的依赖过多，我认为这会削弱人们对它们的信心。而且我认为这也意味着，它们可能没有在履行其真正的职责，即赋予学生在这个世界上立足所需的知识和技能。所以它们几乎变得与教育本身相脱节了。
They can become a bit detached from it. They become a means to an end on their own. I think that is a real problem. And I think that's the kind of thing, we talked about this happening in China, where you then can get that dominance of them. And I think there's that feeling that, well, you know, maybe private schools have this secret source where they can just get their pupils to kind of jump through these hoops. So I think it is really important that they're fair, and there's a level playing field. And I think it's really
它们可能会与教育有点脱节。它们本身就变成了实现目的的手段。我认为这是一个真正的问题。而且我认为这就是我们在中国看到发生过的那种情况，在那儿你可以获得对它们的统治地位。而且人们会觉得，好吧，你知道的，也许私立学校有某种秘密配方，他们可以轻而易举地让学生跳过这些圈子。所以我认为，考试公平且存在公平的竞争环境真的很重要。而且我认为
important they're perceived to have that. And I certainly think there's ways we could reform them so that they do a better job there. And I do share the concerns of people who say if we don't make some of those reforms, then it's not just a problem for the exam system, but it is a problem for society because of that outsized role that exams play in our life. But Tom, if elite overproduction is your concern and you think that elite overproduction leads to... Well, no, it's not a concern. ...leads to unrest, right, then greater social mobility in exams wouldn't solve that. It would just mean a different part of the overproduced elite was satisfied and...
它们被认为具备这种公平性真的很重要。而且我当然认为我们可以通过一些方式来改革它们，使它们在这方面做得更好。我也确实赞同那些人的担忧，他们说如果我们不进行其中一些改革，那么这不仅是考试系统的问题，也是整个社会的问题，因为考试在我们生活中扮演着超乎寻常的角色。但是，汤姆，如果精英过剩是你的担忧，并且你认为精英过剩会导致——嗯，不，这不是担忧。……导致动荡，对吧，那么更高的社会流动性和考试并不能解决这个问题。那只会意味着过度生产的精英中的另一部分得到了满足，并且……
Right, so Peter Turchin, his argument is you don't want to be making... You don't want to be getting all these meritocrats striving for the top role. You actually need some way of damping down competition. Yeah, that would be his argument. He takes that quite kind of counterintuitive argument. I would say the implication of that argument is actually just stop educating so many people.
好吧，所以彼得·图钦（Peter Turchin）的论点是，你不想去培养——你不想让所有这些精英论者都在争夺最高职位。实际上，你需要某种方法来抑制竞争。是的，那会是他的论点。他持有一种相当反直觉的论点。我会说，那个论点的含义实际上就是：别再教育那么多人了。
Because that just, I mean, you could laugh. Robust is no nonsense. But that's surely the obvious conclusion, right? Unless you're going to magically create the jobs for the people to go to then the if if elite overproduction is your fear then the issue is elite overproduction i.e stop producing so many elite people or produce more elite jobs well you can't just unless you've got you are you blessed with the magic wand that would create elite jobs out of nowhere well that's why i need to become dictator.
因为那只会——我的意思是，你可以笑。强有力且不废话。但这肯定是一个显而易见的结论，对吧？除非你能神奇地创造出供人们去从事的工作，否则，如果精英过剩是你的恐惧，那么问题就在于精英过剩，换句话说：停止生产那么多的精英，或者创造更多精英岗位。嗯，你不能只是——除非你拥有能凭空创造精英职位的魔杖。嗯，这就是为什么我要成为独裁者。
The other side of it is, I suppose the other side of it is if you're not worrying about elite overproduction, but you're worrying about you want to get the very best talented people into jobs and into the top jobs. And if you want to do that, that would be good for everyone. Because if you have the most talented people in the top jobs, then they're hopefully going to run things more competently and make better decisions so that would be the alternative kind of sort of meritocrat argument that you do want the competition you do want people competing you want exams that do find who the most talented are and do also uh you know give them the education they need and and that will be good for society but also i mean there's a difference isn't it but i mean just to go back to whether exams are an end in themselves the more more people are educated, the more they're in a position to create jobs.
事情的另一面是，我想事情的另一面是，如果你不担心精英过剩，而是担心你想把最优秀、最有才华的人招进岗位和高层职位中。如果你想这么做，这对每个人都有好处。因为如果你把最有才华的人放在高层职位上，那么他们有望把事情管理得更有能力，做出更好的决策。所以这会是另一种竞争精英论的论点，即你确实想要竞争，你确实想要人们竞争，你确实想要那些能找出谁是最有才华者的考试，并且也（能）——你知道的——给他们所需的教育，那将对社会有益。但同时，我的意思是，这其中是有区别的，对吧？但我的意思是，仅仅回到考试是否是其自身的终极目的这一点上，接受教育的人越多，他们就越有能力去创造就业岗位。
And so the economy grows. That is absolutely gibberish. Not at all. Not at all. Because if everything is funneled through the prism of examinations and, you know, there are certain kind of, I don't know, Oxford Ecologies or something, that's seen as the absolute end. And of course, there's a finite number. But if people's education is better across the entire spectrum of society,
这样经济就能增长。这纯粹是胡说八道。完全不是。完全不是。因为如果所有事情都通过考试的棱镜来过滤，而且你知道，有某种，我不知道，牛津的生态系统之类的，这被视为绝对的目标。当然，数量是有限的。但如果整个社会各阶层的教育水平都得到了提高，
then people have the knowledge. Then the magic wand does appear. Tom Holland's magic wand. It's not magic. It's sensible policies for a happier Britain. I am right, you're wrong. The best educated cabinet we ever had was the Wilson government of the 1960s.
那么人们就拥有了知识。魔法棒真的出现了。汤姆·霍兰德的魔法棒。这不是魔法。这是为了一个更快乐的英国而采取的明智政策。我是对的，你们是错的。我们拥有的受教育程度最高内阁是20世纪60年代的威尔逊政府。
I mean, they were all Oxford dons. They were all super educated. Now, nobody, I mean, not even their greatest fans points to that government and says... No, but you're looking at it again through the prism of elites, through people going to Oxbridge. That's not the point.
我的意思是，他们都是牛津的学者。他们都受过高等教育。现在，没有人，我是说，甚至连他们最大的粉丝也不会指着那个政府说……不，但你又透过精英的棱镜来看待它，透过那些去奥克斯布里奇的人来看待它。重点不在这里。
The point is that if you look at it, there are exams you have to do. There are certain exams you do spectacularly well, you get the best prizes. That's the Chinese system. I mean, that's off. If you look at things entirely through the prism of getting to universities, that's how we would look at it. But there is another way of saying that you take away the whole apparatus of exams. And it's about learning. It's about knowledge. And it's about getting skills and understanding and perspectives that then enable you to kind of create your own your own context i think that's a really interesting point i'm going to throw something else into the mix here it was another sort of
重点是，如果你看一下，有些考试你必须参加。有些考试你考得特别好，你就能获得最好的奖项。这就是中国的体制。我的意思是，这不对。如果你完全透过考入大学的棱镜来看待事物，我们就会这样看待它。但还有另一种说法，那就是抛开考试的整套机构。它是关于学习的。它是关于知识的。它是关于获得技能、理解和视野的，这反过来能让你建立起自己的背景，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的观点，我要在这里加入另一个内容，这是另一种
china and john stewart mill point which is when they were talking about exams for the civil service in the 19th century john stewart mill said um i wouldn't want the best and brightest in the civil service he said if the exams meant that all of the best and brightest went to work in the civil service that would be terrible. And he said it would be terrible because you would then have nobody outside the civil service will kind of have the capacity
关于中国和约翰·斯图尔特·密尔的观点，那就是当他们在19世纪讨论公务员考试时，约翰·斯图尔特·密尔说，嗯，我可不希望公务员队伍里都是最优秀最聪明的人，他说如果考试意味着所有最优秀最聪明的人都去公务员队伍工作，那将是一场灾难。他说这将是一场灾难，因为那样一来，公务员体制之外就没有人有能力
to solve their problems because you just have everyone in the civil service kind of doing it. He also then said that you wouldn't have anyone with the capacity to check they were doing the right thing. So how would you check
去解决他们的问题了，因为每个人都在公务员队伍里干这事。他还说，这样一来，你连一个有能力检查他们做得对不对的人都没有了。所以你该怎么检查
if there was any corruption or anything? And he also said, and this is his China and he also talks about Russia, the problem you would have is you would have like a self-perpetuating oligarchy and in some senses when exam systems get too good and again you could argue this for china they they they do become self-perpetuating and it gets really really hard to uh bring in any reform and change the content on what you're being examined that's the argument behind michael young's book about the rise of the meritocracy. That's the argument behind Michael Young's book
是否存在腐败之类的现象？他还说——这是他提到的中国，他也谈到了俄罗斯——你将面临的问题是，你会有一个自我延续的寡头政治，某种意义上，当考试制度变得太完美时——同样，你也可以用这个来论证中国——它们确实会变得自我延续，要引入任何改革和改变考试内容变得非常非常困难，这就是迈克尔·扬关于精英统治崛起一书背后的论点。这就是迈克尔·扬的书背后的论点
about the rise of the meritocracy. So he's the person who, Toby Young's father, wrote the 1945 Labour Manifesto. He effectively coined the phrase meritocracy. But he was talking about that as a warning. He was saying you create this elite of meritocrats who are very, very well educated, who then think, you know,
关于精英统治的崛起。所以他是那个——托比·扬的父亲——撰写1945年工党宣言的人。他实际上创造了“精英统治”（meritocracy）这个词。但他当时是将此作为一种警告。他说，你创造了这样一个精英阶层，他们受过非常非常良好的教育，然后他们会认为，你知道的，
they're different from aristocracies or oligarchies, because they think, I earned this, you know, I'm morally better than other people, because I worked so hard, and I'm so clever. And, and that argument is around a lot in politics at the moment that we've created, that there is this sort of self conscious, middle class, highly educated, meritocratic elite, you know, the winners and losers of society you know who think that they are not just luckier and cleverer than other people but they are morally more deserving because they earned it through their own efforts through passing exams through precisely this point you know what this entire episode shows is that we've just degenerated into a rambling
他们不同于贵族或寡头，因为他们认为，这是我应得的，你知道的，我在道德上比其他人更优秀，因为我工作那么努力，而且我那么聪明。而且，这种论点目前在政治上非常普遍，即我们创造了这样一种自我意识的、中产阶级的、受过高等教育的精英统治阶层，你知道的，社会的赢家和输者，你知道的，他们认为自己不仅比其他人更幸运、更聪明，而且他们在道德上更值得拥有，因为这一切都是通过他们自己的努力、通过通过考试赢得的，正是通过这一点，你知道的，这一整集所显示的一切不过是我们退化成了一场杂乱无章的谈话
what it shows is that there is almost no topic more calculated to generate argument and disagreement and intense feelings on the subject of exams. And Dominic, I'm going to... Yeah, you're going to have the last word. You're going to have the last word. No, I'm not. I'm going to take your exam page. But Daisy, I can't thank you enough
它所表明的是，几乎没有什么话题比考试更能引发争论、分歧和强烈的情感了。多米尼克，我要……是的，你来做总结发言。你来做最后陈述。不，我不。我要把你的考试卷拿走。不过黛西，我非常感谢你
because I really think that the historical perspective does shed light on the timelessness of these, you know, people's kind of very ambivalent attitudes towards exams. As exemplified by the way that this entire conversation is disintegrated. So I can't thank you enough. Yeah, thank you, Daisy. That was fascinating. Thanks, Tom. Really, really interesting.
因为我真的认为，历史视角确实揭示了人们对考试这种永恒的、非常矛盾的态度，正如我们整场对话瓦解的方式所证明的那样。所以我非常感激你。是的，谢谢你，黛西。太精彩了。谢谢你，汤姆。真的很非常有趣。
Thanks so much. And we will be back on Thursday with, as I said, beginning of the programme, Sherlock Holmes. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
非常感谢。我们将在周四回归，正如节目开始时所说，我们将讨论夏洛克·福尔摩斯。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。